look at the situation in india it is
absolutely
dire what more can we do well it's a
heartbreaking situation in india and my
heart goes out to the people of india
and the
severe problems they're facing the
united kingdom has already sent 600
pieces of equipment out
we're sending oxygen out and we've got
another shipment going out this week as
well
and we're working very very closely with
partners across the world
to make sure india has the supplies it
needs
and of course india was of huge help to
the united kingdom last year
making sure we had the paracetamol we
need they're a close
ally of the united kingdom and we do
really are working hard
to make sure that we can help as much as
possible i mean christian aid have said
now that you know most british people in
high-risk categories have been
vaccinated
we now need to start sharing our vaccine
supplies
with nations like india urgently well
we're already part of the kovacs
programme which is about supplying
vaccines around the world with the third
largest donor
of course the astrozenica vaccine is
being produced in
india and that has been done under
voluntary licence and i'm working very
closely with dr negozi
at the world trade organization to see
what more we can do to ramp up
vaccine supply across the world because
you're absolutely right
nobody is safe until everybody is safe
and we need to make sure that we
increase supply as much as possible of
course to continue with our vaccination
program here in the uk
but also to make sure the people of
india are vaccinated and across the
world but in terms of india
the major issue is oxygen that is our
focus that is the
uh product that we're getting out to
india as rapidly as possible because
that is the immediate issue they're
facing
but i have a call later today with my
indian counterpart
we're talking about the free trade
agreement negotiations but we're also
talking about
what more we can do to help this
immediate crisis in india
in in terms of the trade deal which has
been announced today i mean it is
significant
you're looking at a a billion pounds of
new uk
india trade and investment that is being
announced today
that is hugely significant but why is it
not a free trade deal
so first of all you know this is a
significant announcement it's going to
mean 6 000 new jobs
in the united kingdom uh including
areas like vaccinations so we've got the
serum institute of india
investing more in the united kingdom
there are also going to be more
opportunities
in india because this is about a win-win
for both countries it's about helping
india with the immediate cavite crisis
but also helping india build back
better after the covered crisis we will
start negotiations on a full free trade
agreement this autumn
of course free trade agreements take
longer what this is is this is the
immediate gains that we can get
for both countries uh driving jobs and
growth here in
britain and in india how quickly do you
think that you can work with with this
in place
how quickly can you then work towards a
free trade deal
we want to launch negotiations in autumn
we want to get those negotiations
completed as soon as possible but of
course
we'll be looking for early wins that we
can gain for both countries so for
example there are currently very high
tariffs on cars into india
on products like whiskey into india we
want to see those tariffs lowered
or removed to benefit industries here in
britain
and similarly there are products from
india that we want to see
here in the united kingdom and if you
think about it india is the world's
largest democracy
it's a rapidly uh growing economy
currently our trade is 24 billion we
think we can double that
by by 2030. and this is where britain
needs to be we need to be trading
with those fast-growing parts of the
world to the benefit of british people
right across the country
um can i ask you about the allegations
still circling around number 10 because
obviously we're we're now in an election
week got the local elections
on thursday how damaging do you think
these allegations are
in in the run-up to a local election
well i've been out campaigning
uh in the elections across the country
and what people want to know
is they want to know what are my
opportunities going to be
how fast is the government getting on
with the vaccination programme we just
had the announcement yesterday
we've done 50 million vaccines across
the uk
they want to know that we are on track
with our roadmap for
getting out of the covid lockdown that's
what people are concerned about and i
think these
allegations and counter rumors from
what's going on in number 10 are very
very little interest to people across
the country what they want to know is
how we're dealing with covid
how the vaccination program is going and
how we're building jobs and growth
today we're announcing these 6 000 more
jobs thanks to our trade
agreement with india there are reports
though in some of the papers this
morning
the times particularly saying there are
ministers
some of your cabinet colleagues who are
concerned about how this
is going to play out this week are you
one of those ministers
i'm a hundred percent focused on my job
of getting new trade deals for the
united kingdom
bringing jobs and growth across the
united kingdom getting more of our
fantastic
companies exporting their cars their
food and drink products
their it products around the world
that's my focus and that's what my
cabinet colleagues are focused on
and that's what the prime minister is
focused on he spends every waking hour
thinking about how we're dealing with
covid our vaccination program
and this is frankly a distraction from
those really important issues that
people care about
without looking at the allegations
particularly because
we know they've been you know the labour
party can say one thing
we're hearing another thing from downing
street they are being denied there are
investigations underway we get that
i'm not asking you to comment on whether
you think the prime minister has done
anything wrong he's denied it
but the fact that douglas ross the the
leader of this of the scottish
conservative party said
if codes had been broken
then the prime minister should resign as
a matter of principle
do you agree with that well the prime
minister is very clear
that he's covered the cost of these
refurbishments that he's been working
with officials
that he's declared in line with the
appropriate rules
but i'm not going to answer
hypotheticals about what might happen at
some
future date what the prime minister has
made clear is he has covered the costs
i think the british public understand
that they want us to get on with the job
which is delivering the vaccine program
and making sure we recover
uh our economy after covid and that we
have the jobs and growth we need across
the uk yeah but but even if we were
supposed to question
in the way of saying if any prime
minister of any
that's an even more hypothetical
question i mean that's an even more hype
but there is but there is a general rule
is that if you know if someone breaks a
ministerial code they're expected to go
and i know that ultimate decision is
made
by the prime minister but you know the
prime minister has been
very clear that he has covered the costs
of these refurbishments
if you speak to voters across the
country which i've been doing during
these elections
they fully understand they think that's
completely reasonable
okay look can we talk holidays because
i'm sure you're desperate for a holiday
like we all are do you think we are
going to be able to get away from from
may the 17th
we won't have much longer to wait uh to
get the full announcement from the
travel task force i would suggest that
people wait for
that announcement of course we're doing
all we can to make sure that
we follow our roadmap that we uh open up
the
economy and travel gradually
but the really important thing is that
we don't move
too fast and jeopardize the progress
we've made
people will have to wait a bit longer
i'm afraid to be able to hear the news
on exactly what's happening on the
travel front but
i can assure you the government's
working very hard we say
bring it in gradually is one thing you
know there's talk of this big bang
reopening thomas cook have said their
bookings are 50
higher this week than last i mean people
are chomping at the bit
of course i fully understand it's been a
very very tough year for people
uh people haven't had the opportunity to
travel either within the uk
or overseas for some time people are
looking to
book a holiday but i would encourage
people to wait until we make
that announcement so that we can see
exactly
what the details are based on the data
because what we don't want to be doing
is reimporting this virus after we've
done such an excellent job
in getting the levels down in the united
kingdom so
of course we fully support safe travel
we want to make sure that people have
the opportunity
but we need to be cautious and we need
to make sure
that we're not simply importing the
virus after we've successfully dealt
with it in britain
but to paraphrase leila moran who's
the head of the all party parliamentary
group on
coronavirus she said it is
crazy to look at reopening airports she
said airports
could be a breeding ground for the virus
she's very concerned
that says the group is very concerned
about bringing new variants back in
they want to see this all delayed at
this stage
well we are doing this in a very safe
way
so we've got a very strong testing
procedure in place
for travel we have a strong quarantine
regime and any further any opening up
of travel will be made fully safe and of
course that is why we're taking our time
the transport secretary is working very
closely with
airports to make sure that these
procedures work
but i think it's absolutely right that
once we are able to we do open these
corridors up because first of all it's
important for trade
uh it's important for economic
opportunities it's important for jobs in
graveyard britain
it's important for people with family
connections around the world to be able
to
visit and and see their families
and of course if people are if we are
able to
uh have people go on holiday i don't see
any reason they shouldn't provided it
safe
but that is the key uh question that the
task force is determining
is it safe which countries is it safe
with and we will make announcements in
due course
but i didn't cut i don't think it will
be too much longer no
before we make those announcements so i
would encourage people to
uh wait for those latest announcements
you see that there is a
sort of pressing issue here isn't there
we're talking on
you know potentially the 17th of may we
haven't had the traffic light system
announced yet we're expecting that on
the first so we don't know which
countries we can go to and come back
without quarantining
we don't know quite what's happening
with the nhs app and the
the covid passports or test
certification here i mean there's a lot
to cram in in a very short space of time
are you on track to do that we are and i
know my colleagues across government are
working very hard to make sure that
we've got those procedures in place and
now as has been said it we need to make
sure that we
do have the setup correct at the airport
so we do have
the mechanisms right before we go ahead
and make that announcement so
people are understandably you know
frustrated
you know it's been a long year uh that
we've faced this covered crisis but i
think this approach
of taking things gradually of making
sure that they're irreversible
has been the right approach and people
can have confidence
that when we make the announcement we'll
have everything in place